REGULATION TO BOUCHARD.
BROTHERO TAKE A
PENALT WALKING IN.
THE FIRST-ROUND UPSET
MAKAR -- OFF TO MAKAR.
THEY'VE BEENAND THIS IS ANOTHER.
THEY C
>> Jack: YOU GOT TO THINK THAT
MacKINNON A ONE-TIMER AND
THAT WAS DEFLECTED TO THE CORNER
AND IN A ROW FOR EDMONTON.
A LITTLE CONFUSION JUMPING ON
AND OFF COULD NOT POKE IT
HOME.
NICHUSHKIN COU
BUT TRYING TO PUNCH THEIR TICKET
TONIGHT.
THROUGH
THREE AVALANCHE AND THROWS
THINGS UP.
USUALLY YOU W
AND THEN STEERED OUT TO
NUGENT-HOPOP NET AND
A HAND-EYE COORDINATION RIGHT
WHEN2 FRESH OFF
KILLING THE FIVE SEASON.
AND IT'S JUST AGAIN THE SPEED OF
.
BOUCHARD STEPS UP,
CRUTCH.
INEFFECTIVE.
McDAVID MAKING HIS WAY BACK TO
THE BENCH A
ON THE GOAL BY BOUCHARD THAT
DRINKS IT BACK FROM THE BACK --
THEY'RE 15 AND CHANGE AWAY F F
HE HAS SIX IN A ROW
HIS.
GAME.uie: HE WAS
BURAKOVSKY DOWN LOW.
KANE TRYING TO CLEAR.
SHOT, SCORE!
WENT OFF ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
DOESN'T LOOK, DOESN'T LOOK, AND
IT'S JUST A LITTLE H
MacKINNON IN THE # 2 GAMES HE
HAS PLAYED AS
DRAISAITL, HOWEVER, WINS THESSEN